my problem with a lot of modern women is
you you've been sold this idea by the
way okay yeah but you're talking like
one but like everything okay everything
that comes out of your mouth says modern
women and it's it it's a lot more
humbling to just say yeah okay I might
be most girls today are modern women I'm
probably modern but I do and it's not
yeah like the fact that you always have
to say but I'm not but but but instead
of like listening that's modern because
femininity is just taking in what people
say okay incredibleness yeah so you've
been sold this idea's spirituality that
that involves or includes this level of
hyper gummy that allows you to
constantly reframe things in a way that
tends to suit the modern female
Narrative of like you know me me I'm I'm
high value I'm worth more you know that
kind of thing because yeah it just I I
did the whole like meditation you know I
was a Buddhist in high school and a lot
of the results you you know
your healing doesn't sound anything like
healing to me people I know who have
actually like worked through things are
extremely calm they're extremely patient
they rarely talk you just feel a loving
Aura if you meditate on the heart chakra
that's a Vibe you know no one who
practices heart meditation comes out and
says yeah I'm the best lover but I love
I love I am love that kind of thing it's
not it the words are meaningless the
words are you trying to apply
conceptuality to something and
conceptuality tends to have ego because
they have a concept there has to be
something to build that concept on right
where that word start to define words I
get what you're saying but you've said
that was no no but we're having a
discussion right yeah so therefore you
said Soul the idea of spirituality it's
really like
it's such a personal thing for me like
it just made a big impact in my life
when I don't feel like I needed it I was
young I was 17 at the time and it's
something that's carried through and
whatever
but I do feel like
I've even lost my trailer for like I
can't even remember what I was gonna say
but I just remember you saying
spirituality and being sold in and I'm
just like no more butts no more feelings
just be
okay show your vulnerability
okay you were talking about that's it
you were talking about like healing and
people just going over like old Cycles
right
what would then be your what would then
be your thought on someone who does
therapy like actually sees a
professional and works through let's say
whatever trauma because not all trauma
is an ex sometimes it can be bereavement
therapy which is what one of my
therapies was for people usually think
therapy and they think oh it's an x no
sometimes it can be loss sometimes it
can be sa sometimes it can be different
things so like
how do you view those women then would
you would you say they're just it's all
ego driven or like depends on how you
process it but modern therapy gets it
gets a bit weird because we live in such
an ideological society that you know
therapists a lot of the time tend to
push their ideology onto the goals and
these these women are normally
vulnerable so they've had a bad act
every girl I know that is going to be a
therapist
they're not yeah there's always The
Crazy Ones yeah I should be you know I
should help other women I think I
definitely no you shouldn't
chill like so you know this idea that
we're pushing therapy I think therapy is
just a reaffirming loop of like
ideological people then targeting weak
people and their weakest point and then
that recycles because I don't know
anyone who has therapy that just stops
they tend to have you lifelong
subscriptions it's Financial yeah they
make they have the same problem making
money you're paying these people 50
pounds an hour not if it's free and not
if you what not if you know that you're
done with that you're getting free
therapy yeah yeah you can get free so
you can get three therapy but yeah I
mean yeah
okay so I have I have a theory about
therapy it's like
ah this is controversial I don't know if
I want to see it
I I think a lot of times when you have
therapeutes because you don't have
friends you can talk to and actually
like you can get a lot of the things you
get out of therapy from friends if you
have ones that can actually hold you
accountable but sometimes it's better to
talk to men like I think the most
accountability I've been to therapy and
the most accountability I get is
actually from my brothers when they're
like shut the [ __ ] up you know what and
we're like a therapist I I don't know I
didn't feel the same like yeah like I'll
give you an example I've been in a bad
relationship before like toxic my dad
like told me he's like do you like
torture what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
and I was like damn damn and it's like
as a therapist gonna do that no that's
why I'm like bring back bullying
and like honestly I think a lot of times
like the problems we have as modern
women is because we've never been
humbled in our life and I think to God I
have brothers that bullied me I have a
brother that called me ugly half of my
childhood thank God I might think I was
a 10 right now and it's like I genuinely
feel like a lot of times
like the best therapy you can get is
like talking to men about your problems
because they'll actually be real with
you but hey they can't be men that want
to sleep with you that's bad they can't
want to sleep with you but like I don't
know I like so sometimes I think therapy
is like a lack of Father figures in the
home and it's like a replacement or a
strong like masculine man yeah I don't
that this is you know don't don't hate
me with all the all the people I know
that went to therapy actually my dad's
what active figure in my life and he's
still in my life and I live with him and
he was actually the first person to tell
me do you like stray dogs
in terms of men so you know how your dad
was just like do you like torture yeah
it made me stop and I was just like okay
but when it comes to different types of
therapy sometimes a whole family doesn't
know how to deal with loss yeah so then
who do you talk to and that's the reason
why I'm like with certain things and
certain types of therapy I'm for it I
agree I'm not I'm not I'm not against
therapy it's just like
there's a lot of crazies
I think one of these things that I
learned um from a time was that if
something's free you're the product
and so you say oh the therapy is free so
what's the gain or where is it where
could be like the game but I always
learn if something's free you're the
product which means
somewhere somehow someone is going to
benefit from you having therapy that you
see it as a positive and then you share
it to your friends who then go okay I
should go through therapy and then go
through it but that's like the NHS
no no we're paying for that yeah
so the therapy is from also the NHS as
well like I said if something's free
you are paying one way is true
so from what I've understood from this
discussion today healing is like a
cliche no healing it's okay okay healing
heal go ahead can I just summarize yeah
healing is a cliche if people say that
they're on a journey it's like oh my God
red flag I feel like everyone has had
that I've not heard anyone sit not even
sit on the face I've not heard anyone
say okay I hear this but there are
people that I know who have benefited
from therapy or there are people that I
know who have that they're healing and
I've seen a difference in them or there
are women who may be very like
I don't know like very like opinionated
or alpha or this but they also have the
ability to be feminine I've not really
heard like everyone's been so like this
is their opinion why are you looking for
that though pardon it would be nice to
have like a bit of range in because I
feel like everyone's kind of saying the
same I think almost I think just as a
functioning adult we can ensue that
there are exceptions like just yeah but
if there's no one's saying them then but
no I don't think we have to say there
are exceptions like like I can say you
know men have these masculine traits
women have these feminine traits and I
don't need to say every single time
there's an exception like I think it can
just be inferred
so are you are you when you say like
like why what is what came through my
head was like Twitter like for example
if I'm if a woman's like oh may not I
don't want to use the wrong word may not
whatever drink and sweat okay I'm in the
trash no yeah or something like that
yeah then you get tons of guys who are
like not all men and then the woman will
be like yeah I know not all men do you
know what I mean but we're coming
because that that is ensuing the the
exception is good man that that's that's
why that that statement's just false
because the default is most men are good
most men aren't out here graping women
they're not doing these terrible things
it's a very very small percentage of men
so that's that's just a false statement
when they say men are trash
yeah like like so so when they say not
all men like like the statement really
should be and I've said Not all men
before but like honestly the statement
should be that's that's not true most
men are most men are but no one yeah I
can say women this and then you don't
can all say I don't agree with this so
but when you say that it says more about
you like guys that say women are [ __ ]
women are this that like it's like okay
you can't get [ __ ] shut up
because the man the men that get girls
like they love women they don't they
don't got these and it's the same thing
with girls that are saying women are
trash I said no it's the men you pick
yeah exactly so so and that's that's on
you because you are what you attract so
if you if you attract trash men then
there's something about you is trash I
think I think a way to summarize a lot
of the different viewpoints is that
maybe your your perception of things
like healing Etc aren't 100 accurate
because you just had a lot of different
opinions from a lot of men and you know
other other people in Pearl who have a
slightly different perspective and
you've just admitted that you actually
looking for exceptions when we were
speaking so it makes it clear that you
weren't really listening you were
actually just reformulating another way
to restate your original opinions
I've listened to like views that I don't
personally agree with however I'm like
you know what
I didn't know that I didn't know about
like the more you sleep with people the
less like I forgot what it is oxytocin
like you're able to so there's so
there's things that I'm definitely gonna
go away go home with and take away so
it's like I haven't come in with less
one set view you know I mean like
I just feel like like
with most people everyone's just been
like yeah like healing's this and this
and this and this whereas we've just
said like we can't put things into a
bracket you know I mean and that's all I
think I was trying to highlight no I've
said it this is what it sounds like to
man that's that's what I've constantly
said throughout this conversations when
you say that this is what it sounds like
to men okay okay so no I didn't say that
I think a lot of our opinions that
you've heard when they collect
completely against yours have come not
from surface level or this is what we
believe it's it's more so we've gone
through or me personally I've gone
through deeper levels of thought and
I've come to this conclusion and I'm
bringing this conclusion to you this is
what I think and you may look at it and
go well surface level that can't be
right it's not a nice conclusion why do
you think like that but I'm thinking the
problems the situations that I've seen
um environments that I've been in have
led me to believe that this is the final
conclus that I can come up with I'm open
to change but I hear a lot of your
situations and I'm like okay there are
deeper things that you could think about
and maybe hopefully you'll watch this
episode back and you'll see some of the
things that we were saying because right
now we're in the moment we're all
talking and more so than anything it's
upon reflection that yeah the
differences yeah
no I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible